leur visage creusé les centres voire des
yeux noirs perçants leurs bras eux sont
squelettiques Leslie 13 ans c'est
l'ennemi 9 ans tiennent Noriel 4 ans et
Christine un an ont été retrouvés sains
et sauf après 40 jours d'errance dans la
forêt amazonienne le premier mai dernier
leur avion s'était écrasé dans la région
de kaketa en Colombie une centaine de
militaires et des dizaines d'indigènes
tentés de remonter leur piste grâce au
traces qu'il pouvait laisser dans
l'épaisse végétation
les jeunes enfants ont été découverts le
9 juin dans l'après-midi à seulement
quelques kilomètres de l'épave d'avion
ils étaient déshydratés avaient des
symptômes de malnutrition et de
nombreuses piqûres d'insectes sur le
corps la télévision publique colombienne
a diffusé dimanche une vidéo de la
rencontre entre les quatre enfants et
leur sauveteurs indigènes sur ces images
filmées au téléphone portable on voit
les quatre enfants à gare la plus petite
dans les bras de l'un de ses sauveteurs
tous sont terriblement à maigri la fille
aînée Leslie en tenant la petite par la
main à couru vers moi je l'ai pris dans
mes bras elle m'a dit j'ai faim à
raconter l'un des membres de l'équipe de
sauvetage j'ai demandé où est le garçon
il était allongé à côté après un premier
câlin et lui avoir donné un peu de
nourriture il s'est levé et il m'a dit
très conscient de ce qu'il disait ma
maman est morte
[Musique]
ils sont aujourd'hui hospitalisés dans
un établissement de santé des armées à
Bogota où ils suivent un processus de
renutrition une hospitalisation qui
pourrait durer entre deux et trois
semaines globalement les enfants ne
présentent pas un état de santé
particulièrement dégradé ils sont très
faibles mais ils sont entre de bonnes
mains à déclarer leur grand-père devant
la presse Astrid caseres directrice de
l'Institut du bien-être familial à
expliquer qu'il parlait peu mais était
joyeux il commence à vouloir jouer
c'était le réjouit le médecin militaire
a simplement relevé quelques lésions
cutanées Épicure un état de santé
général qui relève presque du miracle
après 40 jours passés dans la forêt
mais comment ont-ils pu survivre 40
jours dans la jungle d'après la famille
la fratrie a pu survivre grâce à l'aînée
Leslie l'adolescente de 13 ans a nourri
ses frères et sa sœur grâce à de la
farinha une sorte de farine fabriquée à
partir de yucca amer des graines
trouvées dans la jungle et des fruits la
jeune fille savait quel fruit elle ne
pouvait pas manger parce que dans la
jungle il y a beaucoup de fruits
toxiques qui grattent à expliquer sa
tante dans une interview à une émission
de télévision colombienne elle savait
également s'occuper d'un bébé car dès
l'âge de 5 ans elle s'était occupée de
son petit frère et à aider sa mère
Leslie a réussi à les mettre à l'abri en
construisant de petites cabanes en bois
pour sa tante cela ne fait aucun doute
la jeune fille est à l'origine des
constructions et ce serait inspiré d'un
jeu auquel elle jouait toutes les deux
nous avions l'habitude de construire de
petites huttes lorsque nous jouions et
d'après les photos qu'ils nous ont
envoyées je pense que c'est elle qui l'a
fait
pour l'Organisation nationale des
peuples amérindiens de Colombie cela ne
fait aucun doute leurs conditions
indigènes et ce lien très spécial avec
la nature à jouer en leur faveur la
survie des enfants et la démonstration
de la connaissance et de la relation
qu'entretiennent les indigènes avec la
nature un lien enseigné dès le ventre de
la mer le monde a besoin de ce rapport
particulier à la nature de favoriser ce
qui comme les indigènes vivent dans la
forêt et prennent soin d'elle
[Musique]